[Música]
arrancó la carrera presidencial en
México de Cara a las elecciones del
próximo dos de junio de 2024 y
comenzaron buscando aspirantes para
reemplazar al mandatario izquierdista
Andrés Manuel López Obrador tanto el
partido oficialista Morena como la
coalición de los opositores llamada va
por México trazaron los requisitos para
buscar precandidatos y aunque Todavía
falta mucho camino por recorrer por
recorrer por ahora estos pintan ser Los
favoritos del lado de morena Claudia
sheinbaum la ex jefa de gobierno de
Ciudad de México parte como la mejor
valorada en las encuestas su contenedor
principal el ese es el ex canciller
Marcelo ebrard Aunque hay otros cuatro
opcionados en la Baraja y en la
coalición se unieron el partido Acción
Nacional pan el partido revolucionario
institucional pri Y el partido de la
Revolución democrática el PRD por el pan
los opcionados son la senadora Sochi
Gálvez y el diputado Santiago krill y
por el pri la senadora y expresidenta de
ese partido Beatriz paredes y Enrique de
la Madrid exsecretario de turismo aunque
también hay múltiples candidatos y
todavía no hay nada cerrado Pues el 6 de
septiembre se conocerán las caras que
aparecerán en el tarjetón del próximo
año y en noviembre empezará oficialmente
la campaña presidencial pero desde ya se
mueven las disputas políticas amlo
elegirá a un candidato a dedo para su
partido Morena a pesar del proceso
interno de selección y lograrán unirse
en la coalición opositora partidos que
históricamente han rivalizado para
intentar encontrar las respuestas a esta
y más preguntas hoy en el debate tenemos
a tres invitados en nuestros estudios
estamos con Valentina Ramírez estratega
y consultora política en Tamaulipas se
conecta César cravioto senador de morena
y en Ciudad de México está Jorge Luis
Preciado exdiputado senador de pan
además aspirante a dirigir la
construcción del frente amplio Por
México que es en lo que se convertirá la
coalición opositora que hoy es va por
México a ellos les doy la bienvenida y a
ustedes les recuerdo que durante y
después de este debate puedes dejar sus
comentarios en todas las redes sociales
con el hashtag el debate f-24 y cuando
digo todas es literalmente todas porque
estrenamos en la nueva red social
streets donde también estábamos como
arroba France 24 raya al piso e s
también pueden escuchar este y todos
nuestros programas en Apple podcast
Spotify deezer y TuneIn
quiero comenzar con Valentina Ramírez
Valentina bienvenida France 24 un placer
estar aquí con usted
cómo da usted el panorama de este Punto
de partida de las elecciones
presidenciales en México está Clara
Muchas gracias por por la invitación
Bueno creo que es una elección
supremamente esperada o sea puedo decir
que como está pasando en todo de
latinoamérica las elecciones
presidenciales se adelantaron
esta lección Andrés Manuel lleva cinco
años como presidente pero pues es una
Alexandra que estamos hablando desde
hace cuatro años o sea creo que un año
después de su de comenzar su mandato
presidencial ya estábamos pensando quién
iba a ser esa persona que lo iba a
suceder y yo creo que con el panorama
que está pasando en América Latina
estamos hablando literalmente de eso de
sus sesiones estamos hablando es de de
quién va a ser esa persona que llegue
después de estos caudillos porque eso es
lo que está pasando en la política
latinoamericana entonces pues un
panorama muy interesante que yo creo que
para muchos estaba muy definido y no
había quien compitiera contra López
Obrador porque
digamos esto puede sonar puede sonar muy
crudo Pero al final es quién va a
reemplazar a López Obrador o sea él A
quién va a poner y la carrera se veía
muy definida o sea Parece que la
competencia era entre las dos personas
que había en morena Más allá de los
partidos tradicionales que había en
México que no tenían mucha jugada Porque
estos partidos como que no lograban
encontrar ese espacio ahí dentro de la
política mexicana pero en los últimos
meses sobre todo en las dos últimas
semanas Pues entró esta nueva este nuevo
actor
a la contienda que Xóchitl Gálvez con
una propuesta muy interesante y que
además pues se dio en unos en un
panorama muy interesante donde el
presidente López Obrador pues le dio
juego y al final fue quien
pues quien le dio espuma para crecer
quiero ir con ustedes senador cravioto
Gracias por acompañarnos aquí en France
veinticuatro usted está de acuerdo con
el punto de vista de Valentina De que al
principio de la carrera parecía que amlo
no tenía competencia y que su partido
Morena iba a arrasar Y que ahora hay
candidatos precisamente como soach Lee
Gálvez quien puedan darle la talla al
candidato del oficialismo
un gusto saludarles
a este medio de comunicación que es
internacional pues no estoy tan de
acuerdo con lo que plantea la analista
Porque si bien
parece que en el bloque opositor primero
ya hicieron un iniciaron un proceso lo
cual me parece correcto pero segundo han
querido posicionar a Xóchitl Gálvez Como
quien va a competirle a morena y quien
va a poner digamos en tela de juicio la
posibilidad de que morena continúe
gobernando este país Yo creo que no O
sea sí ya tomaron la decisión de que
seas Xóchitl Gálvez eso Parece que ya
está claro pero de eso a que nos vaya a
ganar la contienda está muy lejos o sea
por mucho que la quieran subir y por
mucho que los medios de comunicación
quieran poner a Xóchitl va alcaldes como
competitiva los números no son así los
números que cada dos de cada tres
mexicanos quiere la continuidad del
proceso de transformación que ha
iniciado con el presidente López Obrador
y uno de cada tres mexicanos no lo
quiere o sea que si hay un margen muy
amplio a favor de que continúe morena
gobernando este país insisto le están
queriendo este quieren hacer crecer a
Xóchitl y aparentar que Xóchitl va a ser
una contendiente de de mucho peligro
para nosotros y no lo veo así parece que
sí va a ser la más fuerte del del otro
bando Eso está claro y y los que están
más preocupados son los que se
registraron en el bando de la oposición
en este país pero a morena le da lo
mismo que sea Xóchitl o que sea
cualquier otro candidato de la oposición
les vamos a ganar porque así lo quiere
insisto Dos de cada tres mexicanos
hay una particularidad en estas
elecciones presidenciales en México y es
que todos los partidos por lo menos los
más grandes están haciendo consultas
internas por un lado morena decidió
desde el 11 de junio en su Cumbre
Nacional del partido trazar estos
procedimientos para elegir al que será
el candidato oficialista y se prevé que
para finales de agosto se realice una
encuesta en todo el país que
contribuiría a elegir finalmente a quién
sería el candidato de morena y por el
otro lado el procedimiento es un poco
más complejo porque hasta el domingo
están abiertas las posibilidades para
que las personas se registren su
candidatura y luego habrá primero unos
foros un foro luego encuesta o la
opinión pública se eligen a los tres a
las tres caras más visibles luego cinco
foros regionales otra encuesta pública y
luego consulta interna para que los
votantes de estos partidos el pan el pri
el PRD puedan votar por su candidato
preferido y finalmente el 6 de
septiembre tanto de un lado como del
otro se conocería el candidato oficial
pero a pesar de estos procedimientos tan
complejos para elegir al candidato final
mutuamente se han acusado de que ya se
sabe y que ya está dicho a dedo Quién
sería el candidato Al respecto el
presidente López Obrador señaló que que
por ejemplo xochi Gálvez ya está
preelegida como la candidata usted
estaba de acuerdo con esto senador Yo
creo que es la que ellos creen que
insisto nos va a dar más batalla y yo
tengo mis dudas pero parece que ellos ya
definieron y van a hacer ese
procedimiento del cual hablas y cuál me
parece correcto que que hagan su propio
proceso pero yo insisto O sea la
quiere fijar en la opinión pública que
con Xóchitl Gálvez va a haber
competencia y yo creo que con xóchildán
Gálvez o Quien fuera va a ser difícil
que haya una competencia cerrada va a
ser bastante
la ventaja que vamos a tener porque
estamos arrancando con ventaja porque la
gente no quiere que regrese de ustedes
insisto son un programa internacional y
tal vez es importante darle contexto o
sea aquí en agrupa este frente opositor
Pues el pri que gobernó setenta mal
gobernó este país setenta años el pan
que mal gobernó este país doce años Esos
son los principales partidos que hoy se
juntan para tratar de derrotar a morena
pero la gente en este en México pues
tiene memoria y sabe lo que significa el
retroceso saben lo que significa que
ganen estos partidos hoy cual Entonces
no no es una un asunto de personas la
gente ellos pueden buscar la mejor
opción que tengan pero la sociedad va a
decir es el pri es el pan quieren que
regresen los que mal los mal gobernaron
pues la gente les va a decir que no tan
es así que los del 2018 al año a este
año hemos ganado 23 gobernaturas de 32
estados de la república hoy gobierna 23
morenas por qué porque la gente no
quiere estos partidos Insisto que no
sacaron de la pobreza la mayoría de los
mexicanos que hubo mucha corrupción que
dejaron este país en una gran violencia
y por mucho que quieran poner caras que
Aparentemente sean nuevas o que estén
del lado de la gente Pues los mexicanos
no se van a tragar ese anzuelo
bueno en este momento estamos teniendo
algunos problemas de conexión con el
senador Jorge Luis Preciado para
balancear un poco este debate sin
embargo quiero volver con usted
Valentina y preguntarle así como desde
un lado Ah no Ya logramos recuperar la
conexión con Jorge Luis Entonces le doy
la bienvenida a él y le paso la pregunta
y es también del lado opositor están
criticando a amlo de ser quien
finalmente decidirá Quién es el
candidato de morena o mejor la candidata
porque según los opositores amlo se va a
decantar por Claudia sheinbaum y e
incluso el ex canciller Marcelo ebrard
dijo que si había alguna canallada en el
proceso de elección él se retiraba del
partido Morena pondrá candidato a dedo o
no
Sí mira yo quiero ser una precisión
primero yo fui el senador del partido
nacional y coordinador de los senadores
de la República hoy hoy ya no lo soy de
hecho y hoy tengo licencia y soy
dedicado a muchas empresas y a mi
familia pero
particularmente en la en la pregunta que
me haces Yo coincido con el análisis de
Valentina porque parecía que morena iba
como un tren sin que nadie lo pudiera
parar ya habían ganado 23 gobernaturas
al hilo han ganado la mayoría de la
cámara y no había ningún método que
pudiera
visualizarse para que hubiera una
competencia real con la oposición la
propuesta que yo hice de primarias
abiertas o primarias globales
estilo norteamericano o argentino o
uruguayo
creo que caló dentro de la sociedad y
caló dentro de los partidos porque si no
hacemos algo distinto difícilmente
tendríamos la posibilidad de competir
tan es así que el solo hecho de que los
tres partidos hayan puesto de acuerdo
junto con la sociedad civil hoy nos
permite decir que tiro cantado no que de
alguna manera ya los medios la gente la
sociedad volteó a ver a la oposición y
esta contienda interna que tenemos eh
quienes nos hemos registrado Para
coordinar los esfuerzos del frente
opositor pues ya permite que haya un
diálogo social o están a favor de la
decisión que va a tomar unilateralmente
el presidente de la República en favor
de su candidato o candidata o el
ciudadano puede salir a votar y decidir
Quién quiere que lo represente en las
próximas elecciones yo pedía elecciones
globales que es la parte por la que yo
no no comparto del todo el método porque
lo ideal hubiera sido una elección donde
cualquier ciudadano sin registrarse en
ninguna plataforma pudiera acudir el Día
de las elecciones como se hacen los
Estados Unidos y permitiera lo que le
permitieran votar por el candidato que
quisiera yo por esa razón me escri hoy
acotaron el método a un preregistro y
además a algunas encuestas previas
Entonces esta es la parte por la que
muchos de mis compañeros decidieron ya
no participar entre ellos gente que iba
muy arriba en la popularidad como Lili
Téllez como el propio Germán Martínez
como el propio exgobernador gobernador
Vila por mencionar solo algunos
realmente yo creo que con esta
movimiento que hizo el frente amplio Por
México permite decirte que así va a
haber una elección muy competida por
supuesto se da este fenómeno de xochil
Gálvez Y de alguna manera ante el cierre
de palacio de gobierno pues crece en su
popularidad y ella estaba enfocada más a
hacer la candidata de la capital sin
embargo crece su popularidad lo cual
pues es bueno para el frente opositor
sin embargo los dados están en la mesa
es decir no quiere decir que que eso ya
la haga la candidata tiene que pasar
todavía 60 días desde el día lunes hasta
de septiembre en el que todos vamos a
visitar el país con nuestras estructuras
por supuesto con nuestra gente con
nuestros equipos y obviamente pues la
moneda está en el aire Sin lugar a dudas
una buena salida te da cierta ventaja
pero no quiere decir que por esa razón
vas a llegar pronto a la meta Yo pongo
el ejemplo norteamericano durante 28
años en Estados Unidos lo gobernaron
tres familias los bus y los Clinton de
1980 al 2008 solo tres familias lo
gobernaron sin embargo en 2008
en las primarias para
encabezar las los esfuerzos del partido
demócrata y aparece una afroamericano
para participar en las primarias muy
poco conocidos solo en el territorio de
Illinois allá en Chicago y compite y
obviamente los demócratas dicen déjenlo
competir en doscientos años no ha habido
un candidato americano y no ha habido un
presidente afroamericano sin embargo
Obama gana las primarias en 2008 Y por
supuesto gana la constitucional en dos
ocasiones en todas las primarias se
permiten que gente poco conocida pero
que está en la sociedad tuvo mucha
fuerza haciendo otras cosas de pronto lo
volteen a ver se crece la popularidad
porque hay una alta exhibición en las
primarias y por supuesto se puede llegar
a andar una elección presidencial el
segundo ejemplo es el segundo te pido
que le pido que redondee para avanzar en
el debate por favor
previo De nada más que ser el dueño de
Miss Universo y de la triple W decide
compartir en el partido republicano con
apenas el dos por ciento en las internas
gana las primarias del partido
republicano y se convierte en presidente
de Estados Unidos Entonces yo creo que
hoy que hay primarias en México te puedo
decir que hay tiro cantado es decir va a
haber una competencia real y hay
posibilidades de que la oposición
encabece la nueva presidencia a partir
del año 2024 habrá una competencia real
gracias a las elecciones internas dice
Jorge Luis Preciado Valentina usted está
de acuerdo con esto sobre todo porque la
participación ciudadana es uno de los
temas en disputa Y es que tanto juego o
qué tanto margen de maniobra tienen
realmente en estos procesos sobre todo
tengamos en cuenta que por parte de
vapor México al final la votación será
un 50% lo que se analiza en los foros y
lo que surja de los estudios de opinión
pública es decir según las encuestas
aquí es mejor le vaya y un 50%
el voto directo y por el otro lado
también es una encuesta que No
necesariamente es un voto directo
entonces realmente hay una amplia
participación de la ciudadanía
digamos yo no hablaría de amplia
participación de la ciudadanía pero creo
que sí es lo que están intentando hacer
sobre todo en sobre todo en el frente
amplio cierto que es precisamente lo que
buscan que era lo que decía lo que decía
el el senador es yo creo que yo no
cuestiono la favorabilidad del
presidente sos un presidente que tiene
el 57% de de favorabilidad aprobación un
presidente que es de 30 millones de
votos que sacó hoy podríamos decir que
mantiene alrededor de 24 millones de
votos pero sí creo que lo que ha pasado
en las últimas semanas si le da juego a
la oposición y lo que acaba de exponer
el ex senador pues son eso en política
nada está escrito y las cosas o sea la
elección se termina cuando se termina
entonces también está la pelota en la
cancha de la oposición qué tan qué tan
ágiles y cuál va a ser la capacidad que
tienen Pues de poner esto a rodar y de
yo creo que diría como de animar a la
ciudadanía con una candidata que sí es
capaz de jugar en la cancha de López
Obrador que es pues diferente a Santiago
krill a la Madrid que son personas que
están ahí que son más del sector
tradicional Pues cuando vemos a Xóchitl
galvis a Gálvez pues es una candidata
que juega en la cancha de él una
candidata que es capaz de hablar de tú a
tú con la gente con una historia de vida
Pues que incluso uno podría decir que es
completamente diferente a la de López
Obrador y se parece mucho más a la de la
gente en México Entonces sí creo que eso
va a animar a la gente a participar en
una cosa pues en una lección que
pensábamos que ya estaba dada y definida
muy brevemente Valentina Por qué cree
usted que esta candidatura de Gálvez
puede aparecerse más al mexicano es por
la historia de ella o sea y cuando
cuando revisas su hoja de vida las cosas
que ha logrado
esto digamos que puede ser lo más cliché
de todos pero pues es una señora que
últimamente entonces donde llega llega
en bicicleta Pues eso comienza a
emocionar a la gente y creo que también
el hecho de ser mujer con su historia de
vida y los logros que ha tenido
independiente de Pues de que ahora yo yo
no pues quiero aclarar que no hago parte
de ningún sector político
pero creo que sí los ataques del
presidente López Obrador lo que hacen es
subir y posicionarla justo Esa era la
pregunta que le tenía al senador
cravioto porque Andrés Manuel López
Obrador se ha referido puntualmente a la
candidata Sochi Usted cree que esto da
muestra un poco quizás de la fuerza que
está tomando
no lo que él dice es que es una
simulación del proceso que está
iniciando la oposición y que ya cual los
cuatro o cinco personas que definen todo
en en el lado opositor ya definieron que
Xóchitl un poco por eso porque creen que
es más cercana al propio lenguaje el
presidente porque creen que puede ser
más cercana al pueblo pero en realidad
no tiene nada de cercano en el pueblo Si
ves su trayectoria pues eh
fue gobernante junto con Vicente Fox un
pésimo presidente después fue alcaldesa
de Miguel Hidalgo o sea lo más que ha
gobernado han sido cuatrocientas mil
personas y ahora quiere gobernar a
ciento veinte millones de personas
votó en contra de hacer ley los
programas sociales votó en contra de la
Reforma electoral votó en contra
la reforma eléctrica o sea ha votado en
contra como senadora de la república que
es Compañera mía en el senado de los
temas que está pidiendo la gente que
avancemos entonces solamente es una
fachada es como las telenovelas
mexicanas que dicen que la la
protagonista es del pueblo y Y ese es
como la historia que quieren vender pero
se va a desinflar o sea es muy fácil y
va a ser muy fácil ya en la contienda
pues demostrar que Xóchitl Gálvez no
tiene nada que ver con un proceso de
acercamiento a la sociedad y la y vuelvo
a insistir la gente por mucho que no
pongan los logos del Pri del pan pues la
gente sabe que representa al pri Y al
pan y no se van a ir con la finta de
xochiga y del otro lado pues tenemos a
Claudia alguien que desde que es muy
desde que ha sido muy joven ha defendido
temas sociales de que la información sea
gratuita ha estado en los procesos de
transformación del país y ahí se ve gran
parte de la gran diferencia entre
alguien que quiere que la están
construyendo pensando que con eso van a
engañar al pueblo y alguien que tiene
una carrera muy sólida siempre en las
luchas sociales entonces insisto seas
Xóchitl Gálvez o quien sea del lado de
la oposición no nos preocupa porque digo
hay que jugarla la la elección hay que
hacer la campaña tampoco nos confiamos
Pero de eso a que nos preocupe que seas
ocho Gálvez de ninguna manera nos
preocupa puede ser querido lo voy a
interrumpir porque hasta ahora digamos
hemos hablado un poco de cómo pinta el
panorama a futuro Pero el único punto en
común que vamos a encontrar en esta mesa
de discusión es que nada está dicho y
todavía hay mucho tiempo por delante
entonces Les propongo que cambiemos la
discusión a lo que hay ahora Le quiero
preguntar precisamente al senador
cravioto si hay diferencias o divisiones
entre Claudia sheinbaum y Marcelo ebrar
los dos candidatos más opcionados sobre
todo teniendo en cuenta que morena uno
de los requisitos del proceso es que
haya Unión interna y ya Marcelo ebrard
está planteando incluso retirarse del
partido oficial no no lo ha dicho así de
ninguna manera le ha dicho que sí hay
algo y regular en el proceso pero no hay
nada irregular en el proceso están
caminando los seis que se inscribieron
en el proceso de morena están caminando
están en los distintos estados de la
república o yo estoy justamente aquí en
Tampico estoy acompañando a Claudia
todos están en gira y se va a llevar un
proceso que está muy bien definido el 28
de agosto al 3 de septiembre y se
levantarán cinco encuestas y el
resultado de Esas cinco encuestas Pues
nos dará quien va a encabezar los
trabajos para defender la cuarta
transformación y todos están haciendo su
esfuerzo y el A diferencia de la
oposición Pues en morena hay principios
en morena tenemos proyecto en morena
defendemos un proyecto que tiene insisto
el aval de la mayoría de los mexicanos
no el aval de unos cuantos sino el aval
de la mayoría de los mexicanos y eso le
da fortaleza todos estamos trabajando
hacia la unidad todos estamos
construyendo hacia la unidad y sabemos
que el que está en morena está aquí por
un proyecto no está aquí por intereses
personales Y por eso el que gane la
encuesta todos vamos a cerrar filas en
torno a ella o a él y nos vamos a ir de
frente para refrendar por otros seis
años la transformación de este país
Jorge Luis usted coincide en este punto
Mira yo creo que es una farsa lo que
está haciendo morena este es claro que
esa encuesta Pues tiene un solo
participante no que es el presidente de
la república Entonces yo estoy seguro
que el día cinco de septiembre pues se
va a ir a dormir lo va a consultar con
su almohada y lo que le diga su dedito
al siguiente día es A quién va a
Designar por supuesto hay cargadas
dentro de morena claro que el sistema de
bienestar que utilizan para comprar el
voto a través del dinero este los ha
llevado casi todos los mítines de
Claudia se los llenan con personal del
gobierno o con beneficiario del gobierno
por eso Marcelo aprecia que hay una que
hay una cargada yo creo que a diferencia
de lo que está haciendo el presidente
con sus precandidatos adelantándose
muchísimo tiempo del otro lado creo que
nosotros reina la incertidumbre es decir
todavía no sabemos Cuánto se van a
registrar todavía no sabemos Cuánto
puede llegar a crecer en la intención de
Voto
algunos de los compañeros y viene
algunos ya tienen mucho tiempo haciendo
precampañas alguno les ha salido muy
bien su su primer planteamiento Pues
todavía van a correr 60 días y en los
cuales por supuesto viene una No
solamente la intención de Voto en
encuesta sino viene una elección
primaria donde obviamente yo por lo
menos me siento muy cómodo yo pedía que
solo fuera elección Pues soy el único de
los de todos los competidores que ha
hecho campañas en los treinta estados
solo en dos No los he hecho y por
supuesto he sido uno de los operadores
de Acción Nacional que ha ganado el 80%
de las elecciones que he coordinado
Entonces por supuesto que esta Va a ser
Va a ser mi octava vez que yo recorra el
país haciéndole propuestas a la gente y
por supuesto al ser el único candidato a
dirigir el frente Nacional opositor
migrante de hecho mi primer evento lo
hago en Estados Unidos en Nevada con mil
integrantes mil mexicanos que se fueron
a trabajar para allá y por supuesto
Tengo fe y confianza que los números van
a cambiar si vienen en este momento
alguien
de crecer en la salida Todavía falta
bastante tiempo para que se resuelva yo
estoy convencido de que la gente va a
decir va a tener dos opciones en México
o vota por el dedazo que le va y que va
a ejercer el presidente del país o vota
por el candidato que decidan los
ciudadanos ex senador pero quiero
hacerle una pregunta aprovechando la
experiencia que ustedes nos está
contando y es el pri Y el pan han sido
rivales históricos y para mantener el
ejemplo que usted ha traído a la mesa de
Estados Unidos han tenido una rivalidad
casi semejante a la de los republicanos
y demócratas cómo es posible que ahora
vayan juntos en una coalición y si estas
divisiones que siempre han tenido no
hará implosionar esta Unión
Mira la verdad es complicado fue
complicado el proceso de juntarnos pero
en frente tenemos una crisis gravísima
en el país y no la podemos ignorar hay
cuarenta y cinco millones de recetas que
no se han surtido en el sector público
tenemos ciento ochenta y cinco mil
muertos en los que va de este sexenio
tenemos a los militares en la calle
cuando se prometió que iba a haber una
desmilitarización tenemos el de la
economía en un crecimiento cero por
supuesto tenemos un nivel de
feminicidios como nunca lo habíamos
tenido en la historia por supuesto no
las grandes obras que se han se
prometieron no se han cumplido y además
el 85% de las obras que se entregan se
hacen sin licitación hay un nivel de
opacidad completo y hay un ataque a los
periodistas inclusive a las corcholatas
como le menciona él le prohibieron ir a
determinados medios y con determinados
periodistas porque los califican de
ultraderecha conservadora Pero además no
solo es eso es el sexenio con más
periodistas asesinados por supuesto es
el sexenio donde se las instituciones
como la suprema corte de justicia a
todos los órganos constitucionales
autónomos el que intentó desaparecer Y
por supuesto cuando ves todo este
panorama lo único que te queda decir
bueno seguimos con nuestro propio
espacio cuidando nuestro Coto de poder o
nos abrimos y decidimos unirnos en bien
del país y dejamos que la gente sea la
que decía decida Quién es el candidato
yo creo que la decisión por parte de las
dirigencias de los partidos fue la
correcta creo que no la ideal creo que
fue la negociación de lo posible y yo
creo que a partir de aquí si tú ves que
las la casa se está cayendo pues hay que
juntarnos para tratar de detener este
derrumbe Aquí hay un punto fundamental
del que le quiero preguntar a Valentina
y es la participación del Consejo
electoral ciudadano y usted me corrige
si me equivoco inicialmente el proceso
de selección dentro de la coalición
opositora tenía una amplia participación
de los ciudadanos y luego cuando los
tres partidos deciden Cuál será el
mecanismo y los requisitos pues este
consejo electoral se diluye y dice
nosotros no vamos más acá y varios de
estos miembros del Consejo electoral
eran antiguos exconsejeros del INE que
es el Instituto Nacional electoral de
México ante esta disolución Valentina
realmente el proceso de selección de los
opositores queda como sin este aval
ciudadano No yo insisto en que en que lo
que la oposición está intentando hacer
el frente amplio es motivar a la
ciudadanía o sea Creo que van a buscar
otras formas de hacerlo sobre todo que
México es un país en el que pues hay
mucha cultura de participación ciudadana
Pues con una unos temas de campaña
impresionante yo creo que pues pueden
ser las las campañas las mejores
campañas que hay en América Latina
Entonces no yo creo que sí van a van a
lograr motivar la participación
ciudadana y que los ciudadanos se
sientan participes de eso o sea creo que
agregaría aquí algo
y es hacías una pregunta de Por qué se
unen esos partidos que históricamente
pues fueron rivales y México tiene una
particularidad Y es que en México las
ideologías no se presentan tanto como en
como en América del Sur o sea es
espectro de izquierda y derecha el
México no aplica como aplica en nuestros
países sino que los partidos responden
más a coyunturas O sea no olvidemos que
Andrés Manuel López Obrador fue miembro
del Pri fue el PRD y hoy está el morena
Entonces se mueve mucho más entre
coyunturas que entre estas ideologías y
Quiero preguntarle por Otro aspecto
todavía más técnico y es el frente
nacional y como va por México se
convertirá en frente nacional muy
brevemente para pasar a las conclusiones
pues sin duda alguna yo creo que lo que
van a hacer es reunir como esa como como
todo ese descontento que hay en una en
una parte de la población pero pues no
podemos olvidar lo que hay lo que hay al
frente y es si van a lograr pues
capitalizar ese descontento y motivar a
la ciudadanía que realmente participe
pues frente a un presidente con su
popularidad con con un aparato de
comunicación impresionantes a las la
rueda de prensa que hace cada mañana
pues no es gratis para para poner la
agenda del día entonces Pues veremos que
tanto logran hacer ese frente nacional
ahí Jorge Luis regreso con usted para
las conclusiones Cómo es su mirada
general de este proceso para encontrar a
los candidatos
una precisión el consejo que se disolvió
era un consejo ciudadano que iba a
organizar las elecciones sin los
partidos lo logramos unir a la sociedad
con los partidos creamos un nuevo
consejo donde seis son integrantes de
partidos y siete son representantes de
los ciudadanos en segundo lugar el
frente es la figura jurídica que nos
permite la ley para poder trabajar en
una precampaña no el modelo que copiaron
de los comités de defensa de la
revolución de Cuba o de Venezuela el
modelo es esa totalmente legal porque
actúa con actos anticipados de campaña
los cuales están sancionados en el país
En tercer lugar yo creo que si la
oposición de la cual yo soy parte y soy
participando en este proceso logramos
que la gente se dé cuenta que no es una
simulación como la que se está
organizando desde palacio de gobierno y
en concreto le digamos y salga el
candidato a la candidata que ellos
decidan sin lugar a dudas yo no tengo
ninguna duda que va vamos a poder muy
competitivos en el año 2024 y
efectivamente Valentina tiene razón no
estamos compitiendo con ninguno de los
de candidatos de morena realmente se
está compitiendo contra el presidente de
la república nada más que él ya se da el
año que entra y lo que nos va a dejar
pues no llega ni a la mitad de las
expectativas de lo que él prometió
durante el pasado proceso electoral con
un con un adicional más grave que es y
lo voy a decir con todas sus letras que
es la intervención del narcotráfico en
México en las elecciones generales todos
los estados que dan al Pacífico desde
Chiapas hasta Baja California todos
absolutamente todos los gobierna morena
y ese es un mensaje gravísimo para los
mexicanos porque y el tema de la
inseguridad ya no solamente es que antes
los narcotraficantes o la delincuencia
organizada el día que no se lo molestara
hoy Ellos están en la posibilidad de
poner a los candidatos y de financiar
estas campañas yo creo que eso es lo más
grave que nos está dejando este gobierno
el saludo del presidente a la mamá de
Guzmán Loera el chapo o la liberación de
Ovidio nos permite decir que podemos
entrar a un narco estado con todas las
implicaciones que yo eh que lo que yo
peligra pues Y esto es lo más lamentable
y lo más delicado que hay en el
siguiente proceso electoral bueno el
narcotráfico sin duda alguna es otro
debate que nos da totalmente para otro
tema y le agradezco profundamente la
precisión que me hace que sí tenía esa
duda senador cravioto Cuál es su
conclusión de esta búsqueda de
candidatos
Bueno mi conclusión es que mientras
morena sigue acercándose al pueblo sigue
trabajando al lado del pueblo de México
la oposición está construyendo una
candidatura con puras mentiras muchas
mentiras muchas muchas mentiras una de
las mentiras que tiene la oposición es
que están juntos para
transformar este país no está junto el
pri Y el pan para regresar a lo que
hicieron cuando gobernaban corrupción
cercanía con el narcotráfico
negocios al Amparo del poder público
para eso se están juntando solamente
para eso están juntando que otra mentira
dicen que van a tener una candidata
cercana a la gente no tiene nada de
cercana a quien van a terminar eligiendo
tercero dicen le pido que redondee la
idea que se nos acaba el tiempo sí dicen
que no este van juntos y que ya
cambiaron no no han cambiado nada Y eso
lo tiene claro la gente el pueblo de
México y así nos han dicho en las
veintitrés elecciones que les hemos
ganado en los estados que ellos van a
ganar y la gente les pone un alto y se
topan con pared con la realidad va a
ganar morena vamos a seguir gobernando y
los únicos que estamos platicando con la
sociedad somos nosotros ellos platican
entre voy a interrumpir para darle
tiempo a valentina muy brevemente
Valentina su conclusión No mi conclusión
es pues que finalmente había una lección
que estaba muy definida creo que sin
duda alguna morena lleva la delantera en
esto pero pues está en la cancha de la
oposición pues tener esa capacidad de
lograr un candidato pues uno que sea
viable dos que las personas vean
diferente a lo que venía porque pues sin
duda alguna México le dijo No más a la
continuidad
entonces pues está todo por verse y yo
sí creo que en política pues las cosas
se acaban es el Día de la lección no
antes pueda retomar su palabra para
concluir este programa Todo está por
verse creo que eso es la idea central de
esto ustedes sigan conectados con Flash
24 de nuestros invitados Gracias por
acompañarnos
[Música]